und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein wir beginnen heute
mit einem blick auf deutschlands
wirtschaft und dafür braucht man starke
nerven
das ist die entwicklung des
bruttoinlandsprodukts der
wirtschaftsleistung dieses landes sie
kennt von der dellen durch die
finanzkrise abgesehen nur eine richtung
nach oben
bis jetzt die regierung rechnet für
dieses jahr mit minus 6,3 prozent so
einen absturz hat es in der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte noch nie gegeben
was tun das ist der kern der debatte die
jetzt heiß läuft wie ist das wenigstens
ein bisschen abzufedern
thomas reiter zeigt ein existenzielles
tauziehen am beispiel der mächtigen
autoindustrie
der gelbe beamten hefte den peter
altmaier lächelnd wie eine trophäe hoch
hält wird in wahrheit die ganze
düsternis der wirtschaftlichen lage
selbst der bundeswirtschaftsminister
findet da in einen kleinen lichtblick
dass vw und daimler ihre produktion
seien anfang dieser woche wieder
hochfahren
er ist ein deutliches und positives
zeichen
aber es ändert nichts daran dass wir bei
dem ergebnis von minus 6,3 prozent
wachstum in diesem jahr die schwerste
rezession in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland erleben
werden wie zum beweis legen vw und
daimler heute dramatische quartalszahlen
vor
weil die bänder zuvor wochenlang still
standen brechen die gewinne ein
bei daimler um rund 78 prozent bei vw um
rund 83 prozent so etwas hat die branche
noch nicht erlebt sie reagiert so wie
schon bei der finanzkrise vor gut zehn
jahren mit der forderung nach
staatlicher hilfe einer kaufprämie
ich glaube dass wir anreize brauchen zum
einen natürlich für die breite palette
der modernen autos die alle ja mit
besseren antriebstechnologien kommen wir
haben bereits anreize für
elektromobilität und neue autos werden
auch mit verbesserten umweltschutz
standard in den markt kommen was die
autolobby damit meint prämien soll es
nicht nur für umweltfreundliche hybrid
und elektroautos geben sondern auch für
benziner und diesel
das ist sogar für die staatssubventionen
geben soll dagegen regt sich widerstand
in berlin
wenn wir jetzt wieder investieren in die
autoindustrie
dann sollten wir nicht mit der alten
abwrackprämie die gleichen fehler
wiederholen die wir in der vergangenheit
schon mal gemacht haben
in einer noch schwierigeren situation
und deswegen ist klar hier müssen umwelt
und nachhaltigkeits kriterien gelten die
alte abwrackprämie jedenfalls ist hier
ein abschreckendes vorbild steuerzahler
finanziert den absatz hoch 2009 dafür
brachen die verkäufe in den folgenden
zwei jahren wieder ein
das sind typische strohfeuer maßnahmen
die lehnen wir ab besser ist es die
unternehmen und die bürgerinnen und
bürger zu entlasten und so den konsum zu
stärken
doch in der krise machen die
autokonzerne mächtig druck auf die
politik für milliardenschwere
staatshilfen
schließlich gehe es um 800.000
arbeitsplätze gleichzeitig aber wollen
sie ihren aktionären weiter dividenden
spendieren
unabhängig ob man hilft aber generell
jeder unternehmer aus klug beraten und
im übrigen auch die betriebsräte wenn
sie darauf dringen dass es keine
dividendenausschüttungen gibt wenn ein
staat in einer notsituation einem
unternehmen hilft mit krediten lasst den
steuern von bürgerinnen und bürgern dann
kann es nicht sein dass auf der anderen
seite dividenden ausgezahlt werden die
frage nach der kaufprämie quittiert
altmaier heute mit einem lächeln er hat
in der krise allen fast alles
versprochen
nun muss er mit den begehrlichkeiten
leben nächste woche zb bei einem auto
gipfel im kanzleramt
an der börse da kann man sich ja
häufiger die augen reiben so ist es auch
heute genannt valerie wir sehen da eine
kurve die nach oben geht wie kann das an
einem tag mit solchen prognosen über die
deutsche wirtschaftsentwicklung zu einem
kursfeuerwerk kommen ja weil die
einschätzung der bundesregierung keine
richtig schockiert hat hier solche und
ähnliche prognosen laufen hier seit
tagen über den ticker heute hat man
nämlich er nach amerika geschaut da gab
es erfolgversprechende tests mit einem
corona medikament und das hat hier die
stimmung gehoben
die kurs erholung aber die bedeutet
natürlich nicht dass wir schon über
amberg sind seit tagen geht es beim dax
nur noch bergauf das viele geld der
regierungen und notenbanken wird die
konjunktur schon anschieben das hofft
man zumindest die bundesregierung setzt
hier auf eine relativ rasche erholung
dass es wirklich so schnell geht daran
gibt es unter ökonomen zweifel schon
allein weil unternehmen gerade riesige
schuldenberge anhäufen diese müssen sie
nach der krise zurück bezahlen
daher werden sie sparen müssen das
bedeutet erstmal kaum investitionen kaum
neue jobs unwägbarkeiten gibt es auch
für den so wichtigen export krone hat
schließlich die ganze welt in eine
rezession gestürzt und bis die sich
erholt kann es dauern also auch da
könnte auf unternehmen eine längere
durststrecke zu kommen weil er wie
vielen dank das stichwort unwägbarkeiten
das nehme ich gleich mit denn dann kommt
dass die reiseweltmeister sollen zu
hause bleiben das auswärtige amt hat
seine warnung für weitere sechs wochen
verlängert bis zum 14
juni mindestens eine reisewarnung die es
so nie zuvor gegeben hat sie gilt für
alle länder der welt
das hat folgen unangenehme für uns alle
dramatische für reisebüros und
veranstalter für hotels und restaurants
in den urlaubsgebieten
was wird das für ein sommer normal oder
so wie immer oder sorgenfrei und sorglos
all das wird dieser sommer 2020 nicht
stattdessen viele worte wer darf wann
wohin was ist
gebuchten reisen was kann man überhaupt
planen und am ende wie viel spaß macht
das alles noch simone friedrich keine
auslandsreisen die weltweite
reisewarnung ist verlängert bis mitte
juni vorerst ob sie danach aufgehoben
wird kann keiner sagen was ist die
begründung der regierung nur dann wenn
es möglich ist
wohin zu fahren und auch sicher wieder
zurück zu kommen können wir diese
reisewarnungen aufheben
urlaubspläne geplatzt aber immerhin gibt
es jetzt rechtssicherheit wenn
pauschalreisen gebucht und sogar bezahlt
sind
welche rechte haben die betroffenen
rechtlich ist es glasklar wenn wegen der
weltweiten reisewarnung mein flug
gestrichen das hotel geschlossen oder
die gesamte reise abgesagt wird habe ich
einen anspruch auf erstattung des
gesamten reisepreises ohne abzüge im
gespräch sind nun gutscheine statt geld
zurück die bundesregierung will die
reisebranche so vor insolvenzen schützen
müssen die kunden das akzeptieren
damit würden verbraucher im grunde
rückwirkend und unfreiwillig zu
kreditgebern für die reisebranche
und genau deshalb stellt die
eu-kommission die da zustimmen müsste in
frage ob die gutscheinlösung so wie sie
aktuell geplant ist überhaupt mit
europäischen verbraucherschutz vereinbar
ist deshalb gilt weiterhin aktuell
wer will kann sein geld zurückfordern
niemand muss ein guter nackt und wer
glaubte auf eigenes risiko reisen zu
können wird spätestens an den
außengrenzen gestoppt denn da sind
kontrollen wieder eingeführt rechtlich
möglich bei gefahr
was bedeutet das auf der seite des
bundesinnenministeriums steht reisende
ohne dringenden reisegrund dürfen
grundsätzlich nicht mehr ein und
ausreisen
ausnahmen sind dringende gründe für die
ein nachweis nötig ist und im zweifel
welche grenzüberschreitende privatreise
als zwingend notwendig anzusehen ist
liegt im pflichtgemäßen ermessen des
beamten vor ort proteste der reisebüros
und veranstalter heute bundesweit sie
fordern differenziertere reisewarnungen
und staatliche hilfen
wo steht die branche im moment juni wird
ist 0 umsatz geben und das ist eine
finanzielle betriebswirtschaftliche
herausforderung die von den reisebüros
von den reiseveranstaltern von den
geschäftsreise vermittlern nicht
geschultert werden kann
zwei von drei unternehmen rechnen damit
dass ihre existenz in dieser krise
gefährdet ist diese demos heute dürften
auch einen nerv der reisefreudigen
deutschen getroffen haben viele koffer
keine reisenden gucken wir jetzt auf die
konkreten folgen für den tourismus in
deutschland eine milliarden branche die
mittlerweile ahnt dass sie zu den
letzten gehören wird die wieder komplett
auf die beine kommt denn noch ist völlig
unklar wie genau ist da weitergehen soll
von der ostseeküste die nach wie vor
tabu ist für alle die nicht dort wohnen
berichtet bernd mosebach der deutschen
liebstes urlaubs bundesland unberührt
die weiten strände wie hier bei
graal-müritz menschenleer
die campingplätze immerhin die
dauercamper dürfen ab dem ersten mai
wieder zurück in ihre sommerresidenzen
cordula und norbert krüger wohnen in der
nähe schauen tagsüber nach dem rechten
auf der eigenen partielle und bei den
nachbarn
mein mann fährt schon zu verschiedenen
leuten hin und meter den rasen oder wir
irgendwo ein bisschen unkraut damit
nicht so viel zu tun ist leicht und wir
freuen uns schön gott sei dank
die rückkehr der dauercamper ein erster
kleiner schritt campingplatzbetreiber
oliver behrens bereitet sich vor
schutzwände für die sicherheit des
infektions mittel für die sauberkeit
zweieinhalbtausend stellplätze hat er
für ihn ist aber jetzt schon klar
diese saison wird ein verlustgeschäft
kann jeder im prinzip sicher an zwei
händen zusammenzählen dass es nicht
funktioniert wenn du 20 prozent des
umsatzes bei gleichen kosten hast das
geht halt nicht auf aber darum geht es
auch gar nicht nur für uns ist es
wichtig wieder der der aufgabe
nachzugehen wofür wir hier sind nun also
wieder gastgeber zu sein
usedom kaiserstrand beach hotel vier
sterne
auch hier ist alles vorbereitet für die
wiedereröffnung wann auch immer sie
kommt urlaub in corona zeiten
desinfektion zur begrüßung empfang
hinter plexiglas mahlzeiten an separaten
tischen die mitarbeiter zeigen uns wie
so ein hotelaufenthalt aussehen könnte
während der internationale reisemarkt
kollabiert ist hofft man hier auf eine
wende
mehr noch die krise als chance wir
bieten ein hohes maß an sicherheit wir
können zeigen dass wir diese auch
garantieren können und so gehe ich davon
aus dass viele gäste das was sie jetzt
nicht im ausland anstreben können
realisieren können in den eigenen
häusern in den eigenen ländern richtig
genießen können das heißt deutschland
wird sicherlich als reiseland zusätzlich
an popularität gewinnt doch noch sind
die hotels und gaststätten dicht 150.000
arbeitsplätze im land hängen am
tourismus trotz staatlicher hilfen droht
bereits jetzt einem drittel der betriebe
die pleite warnt der tourismusverband
und fordert lockerungen möglichst bald
auch weil mecklenburg vorpommern die
bundesweit geringsten infektionszahlen
hat in rostock wurden seit zwei wochen
gar keine fälle mehr gemeldet corona
frei die stadt corona frei der strand
der stadt warum also nicht wieder urlaub
einladen fragt sich strandkorb
vermieterin franziska treichel
wie lange können betriebe wie dieser
noch durchhalten eine schicksalsfrage
für den ganzen tourismus im land
keine chance irgendwie in irgendeiner
form einzugreifen und irgendwas zu
ändern wir müssen es einfach so
hinnehmen
und ja es beobachten was passiert wenn
wir überleben oder nicht über den
mecklenburg vorpommern begeht in diesem
jahr seinen 30 geburtstag der tourismus
gehörte zumindest bisher zu den
erfolgsgeschichten des landes zuständig
in der bundesregierung für die schönsten
wochen des jahres ist thomas bareiß cdu
der tourismusbeauftragte der regierung
er muss jetzt eines der größten
sorgenkinder dieser krise managen
guten abend herr bareiß und habe nach
mainz er war als die reisebranche sagt
wir brauchen differenzierte debatte
keinen pauschalen abgesang auf den
sommerurlaub wie viel hoffnung können
sie da geben also dass diese krise
ausmacht ist dass wir leider nicht in
die ferne schauen können sondern sie
wirklich schritt für schritt vorangehen
das zuschauen das wird relativ schnell
diese pandemie auch einschränken dass
wir die infektionsketten durchbrechen
und dann auch die gesundheit und
sicherheit an erster stelle stellen und
dann wiederum müssen schauen dass wir
dann relativ schnell dann wenn die
gesundheit auch dann gewährleistet wird
und auch die reisebranche da auch öffnen
können dass lockerungen auch der
maßnahmen vornehmen können
es wird wichtig sein für den sommer ich
hoffe dass ich im sommer auch dann
wirklich deutschland tourismus möglich
machen dass die menschen auch in ihre
heimat urlaub machen können für die
großen von reisen sehe ich die nächsten
monate noch keine positiven signalen ich
glaube dass wir auch wirklich sehen
müssen dass noch viele länder vor großen
problemen stehen dass auch der
reisewarnungen auch noch
wahrscheinlichkeit über den juni hinaus
noch eine tagesordnung sind
er war es so viel zeit ist nicht mehr
ende juni beginnen die ersten
sommerferien
sie haben gesagt sie hoffen dann auf
tourismus zumindest in deutschland was
wären denn die kriterien gibt es da ganz
klare regeln nach denen wieder geöffnet
werden kann
ich brauche jetzt relativ schnell auch
sicherheitsstandards vor ort um
sicherheit auch zu gewährleisten um
gesundheitsschutz auch wirklich auch
möbel zu machen das heißt abstandshalter
desinfektionsspray es vor ort auch
vielleicht die möglichkeit dass die
mitarbeiter sich auch testen lassen dass
auch wirklich vor ort dann in sorglose
dann auch den urlaub gemacht werden kann
der urlaub 2020 wurde auch nicht zu sein
wie die jahre zuvor ist aber auch da
müssen wir davon ausgehen dass es noch
länger dauert bis die betrieb wirklich
wieder
auch normalen umsatz machen deshalb
steht auch die reisebranche in ganz ganz
schwierigen jahren und da muss auch die
politik meines erachtens helfen dass
diese schwierigkeit durch deinen worten
strukturen nicht definitiv zerstört
werden die politik konnte helfen durch
abkommen zwischen einzelnen ländern
österreich zb schlägt das vor gute idee
also ich glaube das wird zumal die akute
krisenbewältigung machen müssen geklagt
dass die betriebe stützen müssen
ich war davor vor debatten dass wir zu
schnell wieder öffnen ich glaube wird es
wichtig sein dass wir nicht so schnell
öffnen damit auch die gefahr eingehen
dass wir vom zweiten welle stehen ich
glaube die gesundheit steht an erster
stelle ja auch viele betriebe sehr sie
haben sorge dass sie dann auch wieder
den infektionsherden sind und damit auch
ein image schaden steht das sieht man
auch in österreich und südtirol da war
ja ein großes problem dann auch in der
in der fortführung auch dieser pandemie
insofern glaube ich dass wir auch jetzt
mit den branchen- gemeinsam schauen wir
sind dass wir hier ist diese akute krise
bewältigen die stützen mit den
hilfspaketen und dann wirklich dann erst
lockerungen vornehmen wenn auch wirklich
auch die sicherheit gewährleistet wird
vor ort und datum standards das immer
auch ja in gesprächen mit der branche
und vor ort dann auch eigentlich jetzt
ist es aber so dass ihre kollegen in
einzelnen bundesländern die
tourismusminister dort durchaus
vorpreschen also baden württemberg
niedersachsen nrw die sagen wir haben
einen plan und ende mai bis ende mai
werden die hotels wieder öffnen und zwar
alle
also habe ich schon erste maßnahmen
gemacht es gibt ja auch regionen wo die
ferienwohnungen öffentlich ferienhäuser
öffentlich gesagt dort wo es
gewährleiste dass münchen nicht auf
einer stelle sind dann auch das wünschen
nicht der große ansammlungen dann auch
haben wir das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt da ist da aber diese
infektionskette auch durchbrochen wird
und dort wo es gewährleistet kann man
auch die nächsten wochen glaube ich dann
schrittweise öffnen
das immer wie gesagt auch darin konzepte
zu entwickeln und auch maßnahmen zu
garantieren dass vor ort wirklich dann
auch der reisende sicher sein kann dass
er gesund nach hause kommt reden wir
nochmal über die konkreten konzepte und
die schiere logistik die dahinter steht
bislang ist es so dass 36 millionen
deutsche ins ausland gefahren sind
jetzt nehmen mal für eine sekunde an
diese 36 millionen die entscheiden sich
dieses jahr für urlaub in deutschland
zusätzlich zu den 19 millionen die
sowieso schon in deutschen und urlaub
machen
wie soll das funktionieren es ist ein
großes problem des ersten kurses
natürlich da eine sehr sehr große
industrie auch dranhängen 10.000
reisebüros 4000 reiseveranstalter von
klein bis groß diese industrie steht
derzeit vor einem großen kollaps deshalb
sicher auch daran dass wir versuchen
diese industrie zu stärken auch da zu
sichern dass die liquidität nicht
ausläuft auch dass ich gleich ein ganz
ganz wichtige punkte und darüber muss
halt schauen dass wir relativ schnell
auch reisen in deutschland möglich
machen lassen
das haben wir schon besprochen haben wir
auch gerade gezeigt dass die industrie
geschützt und gestützt werden muss ich
hatte jetzt aber mal ganz konkret
gefragt wie hat man sich das reisen da
vorzustellen wenn plötzlich millionen
und abermillionen im eigenen land urlaub
machen aber die logistik dafür gar nicht
da ist also gibt es dann bestimmte
quoten sagt man ihr dürft nur im eigenen
bundesland bleiben oder im eigenen
landkreis oder man muss irgendwelche
online-tickets ziehen für bestimmte
slots an der küste wie haben sie sich
das konkret ausgemalt sie müssen ja
pläne in der schublade haben also
durchschnittlich sehr großen
durchschnitt auch viele schöne
reiseziele machen jetzt keine sorgen
dass aber die menge her bewegt werden
ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
diese ziele war wirklich wildheit
gespräche ist auch dann ein 1 oder ein
freizeitpark dass dort eine ganz konkret
die angaben gemacht hatten wir schon
menschen diesen schritt zeitnah gehen
dürfen und dann die inhalte einer stadt
bisher 40.000 menschen fragt 10.000
menschen und damit ist gewährleistet
dass auch in dem freizeitpark es
sichergestellt werden kann dass keine
größere menschenansammlungen da sind das
muss natürlich gewährleistet sein
abstand halten wird diesen sommer ganz
ganz wichtige sache sein und damit auch
gewährleistet werden kann dass die
gesundheit auch wirklich da auch
sichergestellt transports noch als
dieser sommer wird anders als alle
bisher auf jeden fall in sachen urlaub
das haben wir verstanden jetzt gibt es
berater bei innenministerium die sagen
ein realistisches szenario für die
gesundung des gesamten tourismus das
wäre
märz 2023 also richten wir uns
tatsächlich auf jahre ein jetzt
alle sind zahlen die basieren auf
umfragen die branche selber es gibt also
gewisse auch da natürlich den denken wo
manche auch sagen es gibt wirklich
langfristige auch auswirkungen wie sie
sicherlich auch nicht dass die branche
sich eine derjenige sein wird die auch
langfristig sicher auch darauf
einstellen muss da ist umsatzrückgänge
sind wenn ich sage auch die messe und
kongressveranstalter haben hier großes
leben natürlich auch die nächsten monate
wir groß ist aber auch veranstaltungen
sich nicht machbar sind das sind dinge
die uns beschäftigen
ich glaube da müssen wir schauen dass
wir hier wirklich auch der branche
helfen unternehmen helfen diese
schwierige fast durchgehend und dann
aber auch hält sich schnell auch wenn
dann wieder die sicherheit da ist dass
die gesundheit dann auch gewährt werden
kann brauchen wir auch dann wieder die
chance messen und kongresse auch wie
früher natürlich zu veranstalten
aber was herzlichen dank für das
gespräch und jetzt schauen wir auf
weitere wichtige nachrichten heute und
das macht kasse ja wir haben ein
wichtiges gerichtsurteil gottesdienste
dürfen nicht generell verboten werden
auch in der korona krise müssen
ausnahmeanträge möglich sein hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
schließlich gebe es möglichkeiten das
infektionsrisiko zu reduzieren
damit hatte der eilantrag einer
muslimischen glaubensgemeinschaft aus
niedersachsen erfolg sie wollte sich zum
freitagsgebet im fastenmonat ramadan
versammeln was das zuständige gericht
untersagt fast ein jahr ist es her dass
der kasseler regierungspräsident walter
lübcke getötet wurde
nun hat der generalbundesanwalt anklage
wegen mordes erhoben
die mutmaßlichen täter wird außerdem
versuchter mord an einem asylbewerber
vorgeworfen aus rassismus und
fremdenhass stephanie hatte zugegeben
lübke erschossen zu haben
die aussage aber später zurückgezogen
stattdessen beschuldigte er seinen
mitangeklagten marcus h dieser hatte mit
stephanie schießübungen gemacht und muss
sich wegen beihilfe zum mord
verantworten
für aufsehen hatte im herbst auch der
bundesweite missbrauchsskandal gesucht
den ermittler in bergisch gladbach
aufdeckten
da hat nun der erste prozess begonnen 2
930 jährige müssen sich wegen
kindesmissbrauchs in 79 fällen
verantworten
opfer waren die tochter des einen und
die nichte des anderen angeklagten über
internetforen soll
die männer fotos und videos ihrer taten
mit anderen geteilt haben
insgesamt wird gegen mehr als 60
verdächtige ermittelt eine personalie
sorgt für diskussionen im politischen
berlin
dabei geht es um den wehrbeauftragten
des bundestages der spd fraktionsspitze
hat sich gegen eine zweite amtszeit von
hans peter bartels ausgesprochen und
schickt stattdessen fraktionsvize vögel
ins rennen
bartels reagierte mit unverständnis in
einem brief an die spd abgeordneten
schrieb er die gründe seien ihm nicht
klar
der wehrbeauftragte wacht über den
zustand der bundeswehr und ist
überparteilich
die eu kommission hat ein weiteres
verfahren gegen polen eingeleitet
es ist bereits das vierte und richtet
sich gegen ein gesetz das gericht an
kritik an der justizreform verbietet das
untergrabe die richterliche
unabhängigkeit und sei mit dem eu-recht
nicht vereinbar hieß es aus brüssel geht
polen nicht innerhalb von zwei monaten
auf die bedenken ein wohnen dem land
empfindliche strafe im libanon wächst
die wut über die katastrophale
wirtschaftslage demonstranten haben
erneut banken in brand gesteckt die
armee setzte tränengas ein ein mensch
kam ums leben
seit oktober flammen die proteste gegen
das wirtschaft und korruption immer
wieder auf den libanon steht vor dem
staatsbankrott weil die landeswährung
auf talfahrt ist sind lebensmittel
inzwischen luxusgüter viele libanesen
können nur eingeschränkt auf ihre
bankkonten zu greifen
eine welle von corona patienten darauf
haben sich die krankenhäuser in
deutschland eingestellt jetzt haben sie
sorge dass sie eine andere welle von
patienten überrollt patienten die wegen
corona gerade zu hause bleiben und erst
mal abwarten
obwohl sie dringend ärztliche hilfe
bräuchten
es ist eine art medizinischer
teufelskreis es ist ein weiterer beweis
dafür wie in dieser krise wirklich alles
mit allem zusammenhängt und es ist ein
aufruf nie zu vergessen dass der kampf
gegen das virus auch risiken und
nebenwirkungen hat sibylle bassler
berichtet aus münchen
wir würden jetzt gleich die wie sie
nils reinmuth ist onkologe und leiter
der lungenfacharzt teilung einer
privatklinik in der nähe von münchen
zur zeit sagt er gebe es hier mehr
personal als patienten normalerweise
sind 34 menschen mit lungenkrankheiten
auf dieser station in zeiten von corona
sind es fünf wir haben mit sicherheit 30
bis 40 prozent weniger wie sonst
vielleicht manchen sektoren bis zu 50
prozent weniger
wir sehen dass patienten natürlich
verunsichert sind und wahrten so lange
warten bis es wirklich nicht mehr geht
wird dann haben wir ein meistens eine
sehr schlimme situation schon elf ist
seit sechs tagen in der klinik die
diagnose lungenkrebs
wir werden heute die chemotherapie
starten für den 77 jährigen war es nicht
leicht in die klinik zu gehen
zum einen der krebs und dann die angst
vor einer ansteckung mit dem virus doch
schließlich waren die schmerzen nicht
mehr auszuhalten
ich muss zugeben dass da gab es nämlich
keine frage
chor und inneres problem für mich für
mich ist das erste problem der krebs das
hat mich gar nicht kommunist
dies wird gelungen es ist nicht nur die
angst der patienten die zu einer
schwachen auslastung der klinik führt
wie überall werden betten auch hier
freigehalten für mögliche kubik 19
patienten der regelbetrieb
er gerät ins stocken und gefährliche
risiken konzentrieren uns natürlich auf
die fälle die unabdingbar behandelt
werden müssen so wie sie auch vor
gegeben ist aber die anderen patienten
die werden eben stärker eventuell auch
mit größeren schäden und dann auch mit
höherer sterblichkeit auf uns zukunft
auch hier im notfallzentrum der münchen
klinik beobachtet christoph dort der
leiter der abteilung einen deutlichen
rückgang an patienten die gründe
erstens sind die im krankenhaus über
belastet ich möchte sie nicht belasten
drittens ich kannte mich anstecken die
befürchtete welle von kubik 19 patienten
ist hier zur erleichterung aller
ausgeblieben die auswirkungen jedoch
spürbar
wir haben uns auf einen großen patienten
schwung eingestellt wir haben in dieser
zeit des krankenhaus runtergefahren wir
haben operationen abgesagt die planbar
waren
das hat dazu geführt dass wir heuer 50
prozent weniger patienten im haus
gesehen haben
auch peter gruber hatte große sorge sich
in zeiten von corona operieren zu lassen
vor dem gang in die klinik hatte er
regelrecht panikattacken über das
wirklich eine entscheidung zwischen pest
cholera bei corona muss ich unbedingt
sterben und das ist nicht notwendig beim
ihren katzen wie ich es habe wenn er
gewisse größe überschreitet ist nicht
mehr reparabel ist vorbei die
lebensrettende operation hat er hinter
sich in wenigen tagen darf der münchner
wieder nach hause
alles hängt an den zahlen der
entwicklung dieser pandemie und damit
beginnt jörg will seinen überblick über
die korona lage heute
in deutschland sind nach angaben der
johns hopkins universität mehr als
160.000 infizierte durch tests bestätigt
120.000 davon sind wieder genesen
6300 74 menschen sind in verbindung mit
kuwait 19 gestorben
die produktionszahl also die zahl die
angibt wie viele menschen ein corona
infizierter im schnitt ansteckt ist laut
robert-koch-institut wieder gesunken auf
0,75 die bundesregierung hat ein zweites
gesetzespaket zur eindämmung der korona
pandemie auf den weg gebracht so soll
künftig deutlich mehr getestet werden
unter anderem in pflegeheimen
auch sollen labore und ärzte negative
testergebnisse und wieder genesene fälle
an die gesundheitsämter melden
beschäftigte in der pflege bekommen
wegen der besonderen belastung einen
bonus von bis zu 1000 euro
israel hat inmitten der korona krise
seinen unabhängigkeitstag begangen
kampfjets flogen dabei über
krankenhäuser im ganzen land als zeichen
der dankbarkeit gegenüber dem
medizinischen personal statt den
üblichen feierlichkeiten beherrschten
diesmal polizeisperren das straßenbild
[Musik]
die kommenden oscars können erstmals
auch an filme vergeben werden die
lediglich bei einem streaming dienst
veröffentlicht wurden
bislang galt die eiserne regel dass ein
film mindestens sieben tage in einem
kino in los angeles gelaufen sein musste
weil die filmpaläste wegen der korona
pandemie derzeit alle geschlossen sind
erlaubte die academy die ausnahme
die korona pandemie wirkt sich auch auf
die verbraucherpreise aus auf der einen
seite brach der ölpreis ein damit wurde
energie deutlich billiger auf der
anderen seite wurden lebensmittel teurer
unterm strich mussten die verbraucher im
april 0,8 prozent mehr für waren und
dienstleistungen zahlen als vor einem
jahr
entwicklungsminister müller will die
zusammenarbeit mit partnerländern neu
gestalten
künftig solle die hilfe stärker an gute
regierungsführung geknüpft werden zum
beispiel bei der einhaltung von
menschenrechten und im kampf gegen
korruption
der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
sagte müller er wolle das engagement
dort verstärken wo es einen unterschied
mache und wo partner reformen umsetzen
damit gehe man weg vom gießkannenprinzip
heute vor 75 jahren habe us-soldaten das
konzentrationslager dachau befreit sie
fanden dort mehr als 30.000 gefangenen
und viele tote wegen der korona pandemie
fiel die gedenkfeier deutlich kleiner
aus als geplant
bayerns ministerpräsident sagte das
lager sei eine mahnung zum einsatz gegen
hass fanatismus und antisemitismus
dachau galt als modell für spätere
konzentrationslager zwischen 1933 45
inhaftierten die nationalsozialisten
dort mehr als 200.000 menschen
und dann haben wir noch die lottozahlen
wie immer ohne gewähr 15 7 32 36 41
superzahlen neun weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
jetzt ist der moment gekommen an dem wir
so langsam abschied nehmen müssen
der otto lilienthal flughafen berlin
tegel ist der viertgrößte deutsche
airport normalerweise
aktuell hat der 99 prozent seiner
passagiere verloren die berliner
flughafengesellschaft berlin jetzt ab
spätestens erster juni von der
betriebspflicht befreien lassen wie das
im verwaltungsdeutsch heißt sprich tegel
wird so wie es aussieht sehr bald
schließen und macht möglicherweise nie
wieder auf die xl lässt niemanden kalt
der mal dort geflogen ist die einen
lieben die eckige architektur die ultra
kurzen wege ins flugzeug die tatsache
dass das kein massen airport ist wie
jeder andere
andere hat tegel regelmäßig wahnsinnig
gemacht vor allem in den letzten jahren
als er aus allen nähten platzte vorbei
kaum jemand glaubt dass es jetzt ganz
schnell wieder genug fluggäste für
berlin-tegel geben wird und im herbst
soll der neue br übernehmen der
skandalumwitterte großflughafen mit dem
termin problem der tatsächlich jetzt
fertig zu werden scheint in einer zeit
in der kaum noch jemand fliegt wir
verabschieden uns damit und empfehlen
ihnen an pieper und das auslandsjournal
jetzt gleich nach uns mit einem blick
auf albtraumhafte zeiten für die
traumfabrik hollywood
[Musik]
genau um liebe zuschauer es bleibt jetzt
wechselhaft bei uns aber der april war
ja ein rekordmonat es war so sonnig wie
noch nie seit den wetteraufzeichnungen
er war sehr warm der sieben wärmste mit
temperaturabweichung von 1,5 bis 4,5
grad und war viel zu trocken so im
schnitt fielen nur 30 prozent der
üblichen regenmengen jetzt kommt ein
bisschen regen dazu in den nächsten
tagen von westen ziehen diese
regenfronten über uns hinweg schon in
den frühen morgenstunden geht es wieder
los morgen eine regenfront und dann am
abend kommt schon die nächste
im osten gibt es noch ein paar schauer
die ziehen jetzt mehr und mehr ab danach
wird es erst mal trocken aber nach
mitternacht beginnt es dann im westen
wieder zu regnen
es kühlt sich ab auf etwa sechs bis
zwölf grad am alpenrand sind sie morgen
früh 04 und der regen der nacht der
zittern am vormittag in die mitte
deutschlands aber auch in den norden
während es im osten doch überwiegend
freundlich erst mal ist das ändert sich
dann am nachmittag mit diesem kräftigen
starken wind aus südwesten
da gibt es dann schaue aber auch eben
einzelne gewitter dahinter lockert auf
aber hier im westen und vor allen dingen
im südwesten wird es dann auf jeden fall
am späten nachmittag wieder kräftig
anfangen zu regnen der wind wird dann
langsam schwächer und die temperaturen
bleiben aufwerten wie heute etwa 13 grad
an den küsten sonst im osten bis zu 20
grad und im süden 14 bis 19 grad etwa ja
wechselhaft geht es weiter in den
nächsten tagen da ändert sich nichts es
wird sogar stürmisch am freitag und
samstag eher sonntag beruhigt sich das
wetter dann langsam wieder
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut